i think it's time to talk about calories
again
[Music]
hey everyone i'm just hopping in here to
talk about the elephant in the room that
is last week's video on calorie counting
and why i decided to ultimately take it
down so first of all i feel like there's
just like a lot of focus placed on
strict calorie counting in the weight
loss space online um as like the obvious
solution
and i see a lot of tick-tock bros
claiming that you know weight loss is
just calories in minus calories out it's
just simple math but my goal with this
video is really to dive deep into the
science and ultimately to point out what
seems to never get discussed here
which is that calorie counting is
actually
not simple nor perfect math our team
looked extensively into the research we
spent a lot of time on this video and we
were all really shocked at all the
inaccuracies in a process that is often
framed as kind of the gold standard
science here in the weight loss world
now from reading the comments it did
seem like a lot of you were upset by the
video because perhaps it seemed like i
was discounting a method that had worked
for a lot of you
or maybe i was kind of making you feel
like calorie counting was inherently
wrong this was absolutely not my
intention
and i am so sorry that i ultimately
missed the mark on that delivery as i
mentioned in the original video and i
will reiterate again right here
calorie counting can be a helpful tool
for a lot of people to lose weight i
fully acknowledge that i've seen it
happen but my vision for this video was
to validate the experiences of so many
others who maybe have not had success
with this method people who have been
told that they must be lying because
calories in minus calories out is just
simple math it's science it's fact but
as you're about to find out if you watch
this video
it's actually not fact it's imprecise
it's messy it's individualized and
ultimately because of its imperfections
it's something that i don't believe we
should be obsessing over this is not the
only form of data that we can lean on to
inform our food choices i also heard
from the comments that some of you maybe
had felt lost not knowing what else to
do if you don't count calories at the
end of the original video i shared a
link to some of my more gentle
non-calorie counting weight loss tips
general calorie knowledge can also be
part of this without strict calorie
counting but since i get that a lot of
you guys don't watch to the end often my
kind of more summarized unbiased kind of
more balanced conclusion often does get
missed as i did actually originally
linked these tips there too so i'm going
to leave the link right here again in
case you want to check that video out
now and then come back to watch this
video i'm ultimately on vacation right
now just like trying to sleep and
de-stress
and manage my mental health so it was
just easier at the time to just take the
video down so that i didn't have to deal
with it when i was trying to have a a
nice holiday with my family but i heard
from so many of you on my community page
how positively impactful and
enlightening this video was
and how it helped to validate so many of
your past experiences or inform some of
your future choices
so
here we are she's going back up but i've
added in some quick clarifying edits all
right folks
let's take a deep breath
and
let's try to keep an open mind these
words are meant solely as food for
thought but of course you can pause the
screen or look at the description to
check out my disclaimer including a
trigger warning to those with current or
previous experiences with disordered
eating as i will be talking about
calories and weight loss so please feel
free to skip this video if it's not
supportive to your journey so i had
originally added that clip in at the
start of the original video before i
uploaded it um and it still got a
negative reaction from a lot of you i
don't really know how much more explicit
i can be about my intentions here but i
do acknowledge that it can feel like a
real attack for someone to criticize
your diet especially when maybe you've
personally had a really positive
experience with it again if you love
calorie counting and it serves you well
i am always going to be supportive of
your journey i'm actually going to add
an extra trigger warning here today
because this video is likely to be
particularly triggering to any of my ed
warriors
it is absolutely not my intention to
trigger more aggressive restriction
because of some of the inherent flaws of
calorie counting that i'm going to be
discussing so i strongly suggest just
skipping this video if you have any
thought that this might be a risky topic
for you and if you are not already
subscribed hit that sub button and
follow me over on tick tock and
instagram abby's kitchen alright so you
have heard every weight loss expert on
tick tock repeat the same simple mantra
to lose weight you just need to eat
fewer calories than you burn calories in
calories out blah blah blah blah but
does calorie counting for weight loss
even work okay editing abby coming in
hot with a little note i have a feeling
this is going to be a very controversial
topic so before you come at me in the
comments insisting that i'm an idiot for
rejecting the laws of thermodynamics
watch the whole video i also want to add
that this is not meant to discourage
people or suggest that calorie counting
isn't a good tool for weight loss for a
lot of people it is a great tool that
serves as a guideline that helps people
become more mindful about what they're
eating that's not what this video is
about the point of this video is to
point out how
unabsolute and imprecise
calorie counting actually is and why it
therefore isn't worthy of meticulous
attention or obsession so let's talk
about some of these surprising major
flaws in this overstated equation of
calories in minus calories out problem
number one calorie calculators are kind
of
very quickly your total energy needs
include resting energy expenditure or
ree aka the amount of energy that you
burn at rest activity energy used to do
stuff and move and the thermic effect of
food aka the energy used to digest
certain foods and unless you're like
maybe michael phelps the ree makes up
the lion's share of your total needs now
since the gold standard to determine ree
indirect calorometry isn't accessible to
people outside controlled research
experiments most people rely on
generalized formulas so the harrison
benedict formula is often the starting
point for most online calorie
calculators but it's been known to
overestimate your energy needs by up to
27 percent other popular formulas like
the mifflin st or or the owens equations
are also generally inaccurate i'm stupid
you're smart i was wrong you were right
right
as long as you're willing to admit that
now so just if we look at that one error
alone we could be talking about the
difference in a recommendation between
like 1500 calories and 1900 calories
definitely enough to make or break your
progress on the scale now the reason why
they're so faulty is that there are a
number of factors that influence your
ree beyond those that go into these
predictive formulas so things like
muscle mass climate hormonal status
weight history ethnicity and even your
caffeine nicotine alcohol and medication
use to make it even more difficult these
influencing factors are not always very
easy to account for so for example even
if your body weight age height and sex
were all identical in a group each
individual's unique body cell mass will
be unique which can also drastically
alter ree most of these formulas also
don't take into consideration the
thermal effect of food which could
account for about 10 percent of your
calories and although they often do try
to account for general activity levels
they don't measure specific daily
activity and variations in activity even
fitbits and apple watches are not going
to give you super accurate information
with a recent study suggesting that
wearable devices are generally off by 27
to 93
so just knowing how faulty people's
calorie goal likely is when they look at
their myfitnesspal app it feels
a little silly and obsolete to be
tracking like the squirt of mustard on
your sandwich and that brings me to
problem number two food calorie counts
are based on
really bad science now first of all
while most of us think of a calorie
strictly related to like weight loss or
gain a calorie or kilocalorie more
accurately is actually the amount of
heat energy required to raise the
temperature of one kilogram of water by
one degree celsius at sea level now to
determine the calories in let's say an
apple we essentially put it in a device
called a bomb calorometer light it on
fire and then measure the change in
temperature of the water that surrounds
it and this will tell us the amount of
gross energy generated
this method of calculating the calories
of a food was developed way back in the
1800s by a man named wilbur atwater now
once he calculated the gross energy of a
food using a bomb calorometer he then
fed these foods to study participants
and then calculated the energy left over
in their stool urine and perspiration so
it's like literally calories in versus
calories out but the idea was to give us
the amount of energy absorbed aka
metabolized energy and this is where we
got the idea that on average the body
utilizes four calories per gram from
carbs and protein and nine calories per
gram of fat as my son would say easy
peasy lemon squeezy
not so fast loads of problems here chew
on pack first of all the study sample
that atwater used was
pretty rough he had a laughably small
sample size of just eight participants
and eighty percent of the time
only three participants were studied
there are a variety of factors that
affect how much energy your body
extracts from a specific food and so
it's virtually impossible to say that
these three random people represent the
average human body one major contributor
to how many calories you get from a food
is the composition of your gut
microbiome not only can gut bacteria
affect how much energy is harvested from
a food but these microbes can also
produce various substances like short
chain fatty acids that act as signaling
molecules that can also have an effect
on appetite and thus caloric intake now
the type of bacteria in your gut is
affected by a number of factors and we
do have evidence to show that lean
people's microbiome tends to look very
different than obese people's but none
of this was considered at the time
atwater's calculations
also didn't take into consideration the
fact that
we don't eat macronutrients in isolation
we eat them as a food and the type of
food in which you find them in will also
affect their energy content so for
example the energy in a
carbohydrate-rich food like flour will
be drastically affected by its fiber
content with atwater's general
calculations fiber is included as part
of the energy calculation even though a
significant portion of fiber can't be
digested or absorbed another great
example of this is a food like nuts for
years we were told to restrict our nut
intake because nuts are high in fat and
calories and while it is true that nuts
are rich in fat we only recently learned
that the fat is encapsulated in such a
way that the body isn't able to absorb a
lot of it so for example we just
discovered that almonds have 32 percent
fewer calories than we previously
thought like what else do we not know i
don't know that's a good question i
don't know problem number three calorie
counts are poorly regulated and they're
legally allowed to be off so much later
in 1955 folks tried to address some of
the issues with the atwater numbers by
introducing specific conversion factors
now the problem in the food system
though is that regulatory bodies like
the fda don't mandate food manufacturers
to use any kind of standardized formula
to calculate the nutrient content of
their products there are currently five
different approved methods including
atwater's general factors which we now
know is like super super flawed so what
we end up with is different
manufacturers using different flawed
methods potentially choosing which
everyone yields the most favorable
numbers it's a bit of the wild west
now when the fda does check up on a food
product to spot test its nutrition label
accuracy it's legally deemed acceptable
if the amounts declared on the nutrition
facts panel are 120
or less
just saying problem number four calorie
counts in a food can actively change so
let's talk about how we actually eat
food now when you buy a pack of like
ground beef for example you're seeing
the calorie counts for the raw product
but unless you're that guy that's not
going to be how you're eating a
hamburger when you cook your meat as
most of us do you actually end up with
more calories since heat denatures the
meat proteins causing them to unwind and
make more energy available to us cooking
your meat also decreases the structural
integrity through gelatinization of
collagen and the muscle matrix making it
easier to chew and digest this means
that you don't need as much energy to
digest it so you decrease the thermal
effect of food now trigger warning as
what i'm about to say may trigger some
disordered eating thoughts but chewing
your food also increases the surface
area of the food meaning it's exposed to
more digestive enzymes resulting in a
greater digestive and absorption
capacity this may seem inconsequential
but the additional amount of energy that
you get from cooked versus raw meat is
actually quite substantial in fact a lot
of historians believe that this has an
evolutionary origin in that using fire
to cook food allowed humans to extract
additional energy to thrive and evolve
now problem number five we just really
suck at estimating how much we eat even
if we one day had a personalized
nutrition fact panel that could tell us
exactly how many calories were in each
specific food and exactly how
efficiently our body would utilize those
calories we probably would still
miscalculate what we eat okay kids i'm
going to need to get some clarification
on this just keep entering the
calculations i'll be right back most
studies suggest that we underestimate
how much we eat by 25
and it's likely honestly a lot more so
it's for all of these reasons that i
feel people are often doing themselves a
greatest justice just like throwing away
their innate hunger cues which by the
way is the most accurate determinant of
your own unique body needs in favor of a
calculation where there's like a hundred
different touch points for error it's
therefore not surprising that research
has found that dieting and restriction
is a great predictor of future obesity
and avoiding dieting actually predicts
leanness but let's say somehow that we
found a calorie calculator that gave you
a perfectly accurate number
and let's say you could reliably count
and cut calories if weight loss comes
down to just calories in minus calories
out then we should lose weight in a
predictable linear fashion cutting 500
calories a day means 3 500 calories in a
week and 3 500 calories is the amount of
supposed energy in one pound of fat ah
not so fast don't continue aside from
all of the inefficiencies that we
already discussed this 3 500 calorie
number assumes that all weight loss is
fat loss which is not ever how it works
when you lose weight you lose some fat
but you're also losing muscle and water
with each pound that you lose or even
with each micro shift in your kind of
like lean to fat mass you lower your ree
you've got less body weight to carry
around which reduces the work it is to
carry your body and you've got less
muscle mass which is metabolically
active tissue your body is actively
recalibrating every day every moment of
the day based on the status quo and
current conditions if it didn't a 140
person cutting 500 calories a day would
literally vanish to nothingness in just
three years it's not possible ultimately
this is why dieters plateau if you're on
a diet with a 500 calorie deficit for
like a month and you've lost some weight
your new needs are always actively
changing in other words if you've lost
20 pounds from dieting and your
predictive equations or calculators are
suggesting that your new body weight
should need about 500 calories less a
day than your old body weight did what
we're actually finding is that no
because of this metabolic adaptation you
may actually need about 800 calories for
example less than what you needed at
baseline and this is why permanent
weight loss can become very very
difficult for people but i'll need a
whole other video to unpack that in more
detail so in conclusion the calories in
versus calories out concept
absolutely works if we're talking about
a closed circuit environment that is
designed to never change but humans do
not operate in a vacuum and weight loss
is a multi-factorial process that our
bodies are evolutionarily built
to reject and compensate for i'm not
saying that weight loss is impossible
i'm i'm absolutely not saying that you
will fail and i'm not saying that
calorie counting is bad or foolish or
wrong i actually think that having some
idea about how to read and compare food
labels and having some general calorie
and nutrient knowledge is usually quite
helpful especially if you're trying to
lose or gain weight but there is a
difference to me between
calorie knowledge or using calories as
like a general guideline and strictly
counting every single calorie that you
consume or burn because as you can now
see it's imprecise at the end of the day
all i'm really saying is that we should
have more empathy for ourselves when you
know a program that's been served to us
as being so simple and foolproof turns
out
not to be now i'm reflecting on this
experience i know how discouraging it
may have felt to be seemingly told that
calorie counting is like a fraud it's
not and i'm really sorry if i made it
seem that way calorie counting has
worked for a lot of folks and it could
definitely work for you but if it
doesn't there are other gentle
approaches as well so again i have a
whole video on gentle tips for weight
loss right here but in short some of
them include having an additive approach
to meals like making sure to include
produce in most meals and snacks
dressing up our naked carbs by turning
them into hunger crushing combos
reducing our reliance on calorie-rich
beverages and choosing water most often
and things like managing our stress and
sleep having knowledge of the general
nutrition in foods can also fit into
this without getting completely
obsessive and for a lot of people
having knowledge of the general
nutrition in foods can also fit into
this without it becoming obsessive so i
hope that this helped to clear that up a
bit and i hope that you can at least
just kind of see this as more data to
inform your future eating choices i also
want to give you a heads up that i have
another great video on the way where i'm
gonna be talking about the actual
likelihood of you achieving long-term
weight loss as well as sharing some of
the secrets from folks who have been
able to lose weight and keep it off so
again i'm not going to tell you that
this is impossible i just want to serve
you the science
leave me a comment below with your
thoughts on calorie counting and
anything else that you might want to
know in a future video don't forget to
subscribe to this channel and i hope to
see you next time on abby's kitchen bye
[Music]